en disant au Québec la proportion de
vêtements retrouvés dans les dépotoirs à
doubler les centres de dons dans les
friperies sont débordés résultat des
textiles assemblés en ballots qui sont
envoyés à l'étranger en Afrique
notamment pour y être liquide ou
simplement jeter
l'industrie de la mode est en fait l'un
des plus gros pollueurs au monde selon
plusieurs études scientifiques cette
industrie génère plus d'émissions de
carbone que les transports aériens et
maritimes combinés chaque Québécois
consomme chaque année 40 kg de textile 9
donc par québécois et par québécoise
est-ce qu'on a réellement besoin
d'acheter autant de textiles neuves
sachant qu'une partie en plus va finir à
l'enfouissement c'est d'ailleurs ce
média québécois un point 5 qui a décidé
de lancer cette idée du mois de mars
sans achat de vêtements une initiative
qui se veut une réflexion sur notre
consommation excessive c'est une très
bonne très bonne idée il faut pas
gaspiller
la réalité si on achète des choses pour
les jettes après on peut très bien se
décider de pas acheter de vêtements au
mois de mars mais si après au mois
d'avril on va on va on va se ruer dans
les magasins pour en acheter l'impact
sera limité ces produits là étaient
faits en produits en matière recyclée
cette détox vestimentaire ne plaisent
pas aux dirigeants de cette boutique de
fabrication de vêtements est-ce qu'on
peut pas consommer de manière plus
responsable pensez à une mode locale à
une mode écologique et ouvrir le débat
là-dessus moi je pense qu'il faudrait
surtout parler d'éducation et si ça peut
être un temps pour l'éducation justement
à une meilleure consommation
j'y vais à fond un mois sans l'achat de
vêtements oui peut-être mais pour les
instigateurs du mouvement c'est beaucoup
plus un mois pour réfléchir à la
consommation et surtout à l'utilisation
des vêtements
ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada
Montréal